in kansas city patrick mahomes will be
getting surgery on
his injured toe today now it may not
happen in kansas city but it relates to
the chiefs dr robert anderson will be
doing the surgery i think he's in
charlotte so mahomes getting that toe
fixed the torn tendon in the big toe the
fact that he went to surgery that
quickly it tells you at all what's that
tell you it tells all of it right it's
like we talked about it it really we
should have
all the warning signs were there you you
laid it out perfectly yesterday the fact
that they brought matt moore on the trip
told you there was real concern and then
we saw him play and you're right
if it wasn't that bad right they'd hold
off on a few weeks hey go take a little
time off do your thing you know it's not
that crucial but
i think he's miserable i feel like you
could see it on his face walking around
and like pregame you could see it i
remember looking at pregame going damn
he looks really like concentrating on
something and the more i think about i
think he was more going damn this toe
thing is shooting up into my brain who
knows but i think you're right it says a
lot that he's getting surgery today
already this quickly after the game
i mean the bottom line is that rest
wasn't going to heal it no rest isn't
going to heal it because if rest was
going to heal it he's got months and
he's got months that he can rest going
forward you know surgery is always the
last result we get so desensitized to
the fact that these these gladiators
from time to time need to you know have
some work done under the hood it's a
serious situation it can lead to
infection it can lead to all sorts of
complications there's no guarantee that
he's going to be fine going forward we
know we'll hear the surgery was a
success and he's already ahead of
schedule in his efforts to recover from
it we hear that all the time and then we
find out later that there was an issue
rob gronkowski tom brady had yeah an
infection
from from his acl repair in 2008 alex
smith
alex smith is the yeah i mean alex smith
is the prime example of what can 97
surgeries right his his infection
i think
was was a lot uh more related to the
fact that the the bone broke through the
skin and all of the bacteria on your
skin and there's a ton of it once it
invades your body you got a problem yeah
that deep in the bones and stuff but
regardless things can happen there can
be serious complications there can be
serious issues and uh you don't do
surgery
unless there's no other option
and it's just it underscores that this
was not some minor inconvenience this
wasn't a mildly ingrown toenail this was
a torn ligament in the great toe the big
toe the captain of the toes the toe off
which you push your body weight as you
run right yeah exactly it's a brutal
brutal injury i've had it on the
slightest scale nothing like that and it
can it can really i mean bother you to
to degrees where you're just like man i
mean everything it's so it is a brutal
injury uh there's no doubt about that
they got to be careful about it you're
right i mean again obviously he was
serious too because he got two weeks of
rest and he was worse than he was in the
afc championship game you know like and
this is a guy mike you know i got a man
crush on him there's not really a play
the whole year that i haven't watched in
my homes on film and done all of it he
was not normal in that game and what's
more amazing is what he did not normal i
mean mike i sent you that clip right on
social media last night with the
little inside the nfl thing about the
bucks players on the sidelines watching
mahomes i don't know if you watched it
or not but it just tells you at all
about what these guys think of this
player and how special he is chris
godwin
i just assume anything you send me has a
virus well it might it might have a
virus and it might have some other
things involved in it too so you got to
be careful but
but like the whole clip mike just just
to let you know like it's chris godwin
and mike evans just sitting there going
oh my gosh how did he get out of that oh
my gosh how did he throw that oh my gosh
he's a magician it's unbelievable man
and they're looking at each other my
home's unreal man my home's unbelievable
i mean because they're looking at that
game going wait most quarterbacks under
this duress the game's already over and
we're up 54 to nothing and yet they were
still sitting there like i don't know if
we've won yet i don't know oh my gosh
it's not over yet and that just tells
you what a special special player he is
and it gets back to the point that we
made in the aftermath of the game not to
take anything away from tom brady but if
you put
mahomes on the bucks on sunday night and
brady on the chiefs
well the buccaneers are still the
champion that's just a part of the
conversation i always feel like gets
missed a little bit with the
quarterbacks in general and that's not
to take anything away from tom brady
brady is so amazing damn i mean he
really is his leadership skills the
stories you continue to hear everything
like that the greatest leader the
greatest people skills in the history of
the quarterback position that's not even
the question anymore
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports